hey so good afternoon everyone and
thanks a lot for sticking around today
when the Osprey of talks it's been and
it's my first time at Strange Loop and I
am just totally floored by how warm and
welcoming this community is and just the
level of knowledge being shared here and
I do want to get quick moment to thank
Alex in the whole strange with team for
organizing such an amazing inclusive
conference and we really all owe them a
big debt of gratitude for putting this
together so the title of my talk this
afternoon is towards an open reason
available web if you came here expecting
something about machine learning I
regret to inform you that this has
nothing to do with machine learning the
ML here is for metalanguages
so that's more up your up your alley
then welcome the idea for this talk
really comes out of two of my passions
the first is trying to make the web more
inclusive to new developers and the
second is canvas newer exciting
programming language called reason ml
but first things first let's be honest
with one another it is 3:30 p.m. it's
after lunch
maybe you got that second round of
coffee but I'm sort of assuming that a
lot of you are starting to hit that hour
where where your mind is a little tired
and maybe your eyes are too maybe you're
thinking about those celebrations with
people after the conference today and
but I bet you know you all being folks
that strange loop a lot of you are still
totally here and focused but kind of
taking into account where we all might
be at I decided to make this talk a
little bit more of a story and it's a
story about a language and the community
that formed around that language it's
also a story about the future of the web
and how I think reason or something like
it and can give us some insight into
what that feature might look like and
finally it's a story about how we create
cultures around open source especially
in new programming languages where
documentation might be sparse and you
might need to be a bit more advanced to
get
how can we kind of reduce that barrier
in new programming languages so before
we get too deep into the story you
should know a little bit about Who I am
and why I'm up here so my name is Parker
I'm a software engineer at formidable
you can find me on Twitter and on github
for those of you who don't know about
formidable we're this pretty unique
little JavaScript consultancy our model
involves embedding with teams at
companies across the world and our goal
is basically to help them level up ship
their products and become better
engineers and kinder people in the
process and it's a really really fun job
to have we have offices in Seattle
London Phoenix Denver and also a bunch
of remote folks we actually just opened
up the EU to remote folks so definitely
come chat with me if you're interested
if you have heard of formidable before
it is probably through our open-source
practice maybe you've heard of libraries
like spectacle that is a presentation
library for react and it's actually what
this presentation is written in there's
also victory which is a database library
for react allowing you to do all sorts
of complex charting and visualization we
just recently launched Oracle version 1
this is a graph QL client for react kind
of similar to Apollo client but about
half the size and it actually runs quite
a bit faster and then just this past
spring we also released run package
which is a metadata explorer for
packages on the NPM registry so a lot of
cool things happening in formidable open
source and I work a lot on that side of
the business
I have stickers can talk to me about it
really yeah open-source is a core part
of our identity and definitely my
identity as a as a developer and kind of
because of that we had this meeting once
a year where we bring everyone from
every single office all to Seattle for a
week to basically just talk about trends
we've noticed in how the web is changing
whether it is from working an open
source or the client projects that we
work on and
we sort of try to ask each other
questions about how we think the web is
gonna change and this is kind of both on
a short temporal scale like where is it
going in the next year but also
longer-term in the next five how might
the web evolve and really where we're
asking each other how do we want to be
involved in that transformation as
open-source developers and how can we
support our fellow software developers
along that path so let me take you back
to early 2018 I had kind of just started
at formidable at this time and that was
when I was being involved in this
discussion for the first time and we
were talking about the changes that
we're trying to see in the open-source
community and the web community and also
what our clients were asking for and we
saw two really distinct patterns
emerging the first thing was that static
typing was really starting to eat the
web so teams were latching on to this
idea that go figure a compile time type
checking step could maybe eliminate bugs
from web applications of course this
isn't a new concept in programming but
it was kind of new for the web at that
time and around 2018 was when the
JavaScript type checkers like typescript
and flow we're sort of reaching this
this level of maturity where they could
be used in production and provide some
actual benefit the state of Jas survey
from earlier that year had sort of bore
that out a lot of people were excited
about typescript in particular teams
were adopting it at a super high rate
but also the interest in learning either
typescript or flow was also super high
you can see that reason did actually
make it onto this list all the way at
the end kind of the language was in its
infancy at that point now as someone who
had used typescript sent version one at
a previous company this actually really
surprised me we had found that the type
inference in typescript was absolutely
terrible and our team wasn't super
disciplined about actually writing our
types so we were essentially getting
absolutely no benefit from using
typescript at that time too the type
declarations for third-party libraries
were distributed via this tool called
typings that didn't work so well
moreover a lot of the type declarations
for third-party libraries were just
flat-out incorrect so it actually break
the compiler when you try to use
third-party libraries as you might
expect that makes writing JavaScript
pretty darn difficult nowadays we have
the @ types repository and and
definitely typed that Microsoft really
maintains and does a great job of so
this has really evolved but previously
it used to be really difficult
this kind of Wed to the rise of what I
like to call any script which was
basically JavaScript code bases written
in typescript with the illusion of
static type checking and really all of
your types were just any and you were
sort of flying by the seat of your pants
and the other thing that really hurt was
the super slow compilation time so right
every time you're trying to hot reload
your app typescript is trying to run
full type checking and then handoff to
babble or another transpiler to actually
output some es5 compliant javascript and
this just really a that productivity for
my team these things have all gotten a
little bit better but as Josh's tweet
kind of shows I think community
frustration around typescript is still
pretty high here's an example error
message in typescript and as you can see
like it's just kind of non decipherable
I'm trying to figure out what's wrong
when the compiler gets upset is
challenging and for that reason a lot of
JavaScript developers just sort of give
up but at the same time as someone who
has always been kind of interested in
type systems I actually did find that
using a type system was fundamentally
changing how I wrote code for the better
it made me a much better reader of code
and a much better reviewer of code and I
was really able to see how different
pieces of a codebase interlinked and I
was able to actually kind of see bugs in
my co-workers code before they ever
emerged and now I don't think I'd ever
go back to writing JavaScript without a
type system the second trend we were
really strange
was that and people were super
interested in this story around
compiling to JavaScript your JavaScript
weirdness is well known to I think
probably a lot of people in this room
and so people were searching for these
alternatives that could actually compile
to JavaScript instead so that we
wouldn't have to deal with the insanity
and around this time web assembly spec
was being standardized and and people
were getting excited to play with it
Elm had just sort of come out and gained
some traction and a lot of people were
excited about that because of static
typing and the first prototypes of spelt
had come out people are kind of toying
with this idea of a pre compile step
rather than the virtual DOM and the
browser and it was all pretty
interesting but it kind of felt a little
bit like people were all getting you
know aboard their respective hype trains
and up formidable when we're thinking
about the technologies that we want to
invest in we're really looking for
technologies where there's a good sort
of open source community and open source
culture that has been started there from
the beginning and for that reason reason
was an interesting technology that kind
of caught our eye its promise was a
little bit different than everything
else we had seen so I advertised that it
had this incredible type system with
100% accurate type inference and and
that was really kind of the key selling
point for me I was like wait I can get
type safety without actually writing my
types and that really blew my mind it
also talked about this lightning quick
compilation process and noah ii rebuilds
of large projects so i was used to kind
of waiting around for my typescript to
compile maybe I would check slack get
distracted
go back still wasn't done check slack
again so the thought of having really
fast rebuilds was exciting to me and
then it could also compile both to web
and to native and and this was something
that really interested us as well
because we were starting to write a lot
native apps and electron at that time
and we wanted to see if we could do it
without shipping the entirety of
chromium into our native apps
so that was pretty exciting so I went
home and I did some kind of like a
little bit of digging around reason and
then I actually figured out that reason
is really just a syntax for this other
language called Oh camel and Oh camel is
really pretty darn interesting it
actually allows for syntactic extensions
to the language so that actually allowed
the reason core team to basically define
a new syntax that would compile into
into Oh camel code what was cool about
that is that they could then make the
syntax look like whatever they wanted to
and they decided well we want to make
whoo camel useful for JavaScript
developers so let's make reason and kind
of look like JavaScript and that's
really at the end of the day all it is
for those of you who haven't heard of o
camel a brief sort of TL DR on the
language so it's a functional statically
typed language traditionally it's been
used in these academic environments and
its really known for its performance and
practicality for systems programming and
type inference so really nothing to do
with the web for a long time and it
belongs to the family of meta languages
that kind of began to crop up in the 70s
and you know it actually came out in
1996 this was a pretty old technology
and it was interesting for me to have
that moment of realizing like oh this is
something that's kind of time-tested
it's a little bit unique about Oh camel
is that it actually unlike other
functional languages it does have
support for mutability and side-effects
kind of escape hatches to do not things
that aren't traditionally sort of
allowed in FP and like I said it allows
for those syntactic extensions to the
language via this feature called PBX
that actually allows you to kind of
rewrite your ast at compile time it's
it's pretty darn cool so just to give
you kind of a better sense of how reason
and Oh camel and how everything fits
together we'll take a look at a super
simple diagram so this is from dr. axel
rash Meyers
this diagrams can the first thing you
might encounter when exploring reason
and and so yeah you can really see that
reason branches off pretty early it's
it's basically just an alternate syntax
for Oh camel and then the reason team
wrote a parser that will actually parse
the reason syntax into a no camel ast
and then from there you basically just
hand that ast to whatever back-end you
want to use so you can pass it to a
camel see and get byte code okay ml opt
and get really high-performance native
code close to C or C++ speed and then
you can run it in through buccal script
which we'll talk about in a little bit
and you can actually get JavaScript out
of it so that's kind of how it all fits
together and like I said this is a
pretty cool realization that what was
new was actually really old and that
maybe a little bit more excited to
actually invest in reason because well
everything else felt a little bit high P
at the time I was like oh if okay ml has
been engineered over decades then I feel
sort of good investing in something
where maybe some of those language
hurdles have kind of been figured out I
also did some digging and realized that
okay Moe had already been supporting the
web ecosystem in ways I didn't know so
flow the type checker from Facebook for
JavaScript is actually written in Oh
camel and actually the very first
prototypes of react were written in
standard ml before they ever got into
JavaScript and it's kind of cool the
author of react is also the author of
reason ml and he sort of intended react
to be written in a language kind of like
reason and it just wasn't available at
the time awesome so yeah I went home I
started playing with the language I got
really excited about how good the air
handling was I'm so excited that I like
very narrowly decided to tweet about it
and it was really fun I also joined the
reason ml discord and what I found there
actually really surprised me I was able
to ask questions of community members Oh
the time they were often core
contributors to the language or actually
the original language authors themselves
and they would just get back to me
within seconds with answers to my what
felt like very naive questions I think I
had up until that point been used to
JavaScript kind of being this entity
that I had no say and influencing and I
think the reason community did something
really unique in creating this discord
and that they allowed newcomers to the
language to actually have a say in how
the language evolved what felt
comfortable and uncomfortable and they
took all that feedback and really
embraced can this open design yeah like
I said this was totally novel for me
especially kind of in the world of
JavaScript tc39 and the browser's kind
of handing the rules down to us the
thought that I could actually maybe try
to influence how the language evolved
was was really super cool what's also
great about the recent community is it's
actually working to kind of bring
together the JavaScript and Okemo
communities to create something mutually
beneficial and I think that's pretty
unique those communities previously
didn't really talk to one another so
it's awesome to see them coming together
now at the same time in embracing an
open-source design I think you go
through some challenges yet you have to
kind of decide which recommendations
from new users are design elements which
things really make sense to belong in
the core of the language and what
commentary is really just bike shedding
it's really just a newcomer to the
language trying something and then not
necessarily liking it for some sort of
reason and the boundary between those
things I think is actually super subtle
and this leads into broader questions
about who we listen to in communities
especially in new communities when we're
creating programming languages whose
opinions matter whose voices are
elevated and I think the reason team has
done an awesome job sort of considering
a lot of those questions when they
decide on how the language changes
at the same time for that reason the
language has undergone three syntax
changes major syntax changes in its
first two and a half years I think
that's the result of sort of this kind
of rapid prototyping approach that
they're taking and also the open source
designed to the language where they're
kind of realizing that they need to make
dramatic shifts but I really think
that's trying to stabilize and it's kind
of maximizing the best of the JavaScript
and Okemo communities what was cool is
well reason was being developed there
were actually tools being developed in
parallel and the most important of these
was probably buccal script so buccal
script was created by Han boseong at
Bloomberg he kind of got interested in
this idea of could I compile a camel to
JavaScript and yes he could he actually
wrote this full compiler and because
reason can be parsed into no camel ast
it works for reason as well so that was
a pretty amazing accomplishment
what's cool about buccal script as well
is that it can make a lot of heavy
compiled time optimizations to your
JavaScript so reason in our camel are
completely sound languages there's
really great type inference and type
safety that also means when they go to
compile to JavaScript they can actually
so remove code that you typically would
write in your JavaScript programs to
avoid type errors instead they can use
the type system to basically determine
that we don't need to include those
extra branches that means that the
JavaScript produced by writing reason is
often way more performant than
JavaScript you would write by hand and
that's pretty darn exciting to me and
the last thing is that that output is
actually human readable so we're sort of
be used to the compiled to j/s languages
producing something that no human could
actually look at and understand and
buccal scripts output is actually very
readable you can open it up and more or
less understand what's going on with it
probably the best thing about it too is
that you
have this guaranteed type soundness in
just milliseconds and really what I mean
by that is you are never annotating your
types when you're writing a reason
program and compiling it to JavaScript
you can in some unique cases where it's
necessary but it's almost never
necessary and actually a quean build
they recently benchmarked the latest
version of the buccal script compiler a
quean build of 1,250 files runs in about
4.2 seconds and then a rebuild of that
project with a small change to one or
two files will actually complete in less
than 100 milliseconds so you're getting
full type safety without writing any
types and you're compiling it on no 2nd
scale so it's really pretty powerful and
I'm absolutely stoked about it the types
are also actually mathematically proven
to be correct I don't know how that
works but it's it's really quite
fascinating and I'll kind of show off
the benefits of this type inference and
just a really basic example and we'll
look at some typescript code and then
the reason equivalent just to kind of
show how how those things differ cool so
let me scroll to the top here so this is
just some really basic typescript code
let's say that you have just a simple
identity function it takes in some input
and it returns that input so typescript
is actually going to infer this function
as being of type any returns any so type
scripts type inference algorithm is
based on this notion of determining a
best common type kind of looking at a
function like the identity function it
needs to determine well what is the
range of possible values that could be
passed into this so you know you could
pass a string or a number maybe an array
an object no undefined kind of all these
different things and you're going to
return that same type so typescript kind
of infers that the the best common type
for all of those types is just any this
kind of comes to bite you later on so
what today we call the ID function
with a string type just a single
character type script will actually
infer this ID stir variable as being of
type any even though it's pretty easy
from our perspective to see well that's
obviously going to be of type string
same if we pass it an integer it's still
gonna infer that as being of type any
you can of course get around that by
actually writing your type annotations
but let's see how reason kind of differs
from that process cool so this is kind
of the equivalent reason code we have
our identity function and reason
actually uses type parameters to sort of
specify the type of this function so
this would all apostrophe a is a type
render you can kind of think of it like
a generic in Java or C sharp and that's
actually automatically inferred by the
compiler and it's basically saying hey
whatever is passed to this function
return the same type as the input what
that means is that if we call the ID
function with a data structure of type
char the compiler will correctly infer
that as being of type char if we call it
with a data structure of type int it
will correctly infer that variable as
having type int so again this is without
any type in annotations it just kind of
figures this out for you and that's kind
of the real big difference between
typescript and reason and this is
actually a called bit the hindley-milner
type system it's what backs reason and
it really focuses on this principle of
that for any expression it can have at
most one type and that's what allows it
to do this or very very precise type
inference so I hope maybe that blew a
few minds it's not only blew my mind
when I saw that for the first time and
it kind of felt like reason was getting
the dynamism of JavaScript with you know
a truly sound type system behind it and
I was like this seems like the holy
grail that I've been searching for and
so I got really excited by that and I
decided I wanted to start working on
reason in the open source community
and reason has actually an awesome open
source community because there's so much
to do so I started getting involved on
github and one of the biggest kind of
undertakings that exists right now is
writing those like buccal script
bindings to third-party JavaScript
libraries you can kind of think of it
like writing the type declarations for
they're probably JavaScript libraries
that's that's actually what allows
reason to Interop safely with JavaScript
libraries natively and really come
another cool thing that's been springing
up and that's I think a little bit more
exciting is this notion of can we write
libraries that are useful for both the
JavaScript and no Kamel communities at
the same time and one of the projects
that's really doing this is called wonka
and this is a library written by my
friend and colleague Phil plucked in who
is also a member of the styled
components core team and he was also the
lead author behind Oracle V 1 at
formidable and Wonka is is pretty
interesting I worked on the tests and
documentation for it it's described as
this lightweight iterable and observable
library loosely based on the call bag
spec that probably doesn't mean a whole
lot to folks but you can kind of think
of it like a lighter weight rxjs it's
kind of in the broader family of
reactive programming functional reactive
programming and this idea of the call
bags back is basically a way for you to
pass callbacks from entities called
sources which are kind of like streams
of data and then entities called syncs
which you can think of this kind of
receivers of data so I'm not going to go
too deep into how this works what's
actually more important is how it's
written and distributed so wonka
actually works both in native code bases
and in web code bases all from a single
source and the way we do this is we
actually have the source code written in
reason and because reason can be parsed
into the oh camel ast it can also work
in oh camel code bases and then you can
compile it down to high performance
native
code or bike code but Phil did something
pretty clever when he started working on
this library and he wrote it in such a
way that it maintains consistent
behavior when run through the buckle
script compiler meaning it can run
exactly the same way on the web and then
by distributing the JavaScript build
artifacts with the NPM package he also
added type definitions for typescript
and flow we get to a point where we have
a library that can work from a single
source in five different code bases and
that was a pretty unique and sort of
mind-bending idea when I first saw this
I think you know at this point in
software where we're kind of a little
bit obsessed with this idea of
cross-platform apps you know we're
really latching on to things like
electron in flutter to kind of see can
we create apps from a single codebase
and run it in all of these different
environments but I think we've spent
West time considering the idea of
cross-platform libraries can we as
open-source authors write libraries that
can be useful for people in different
communities and really to show you how
similar these api's are when used in
reason and used in JavaScript or
typescript or flow let's take a look at
just some really basic wonka code cool
all right so this is some really super
simple reason code we're gonna go ahead
and open the Wonka module this basically
brings all the functions from Wonka into
the local scope then we call Wonka's
from array method and this basically
turns a static array into a source or a
stream and then from there we can use
reasons pipe operator to pass it to this
scan operator you can kind of think of
scan as kind of like reduce it allows
you to pass an accumulator and get a
value from this source and then you can
do sort of what you want with that over
time and then just for fun we'll pass it
through a delay operator for 100
milliseconds and then we'll subscribe to
that output
and just print it out so this will
actually keep running for every value in
the source so once we've hit this
describe we're actually going to go back
up to the scan run the next accumulation
dawei about 100 milliseconds subscribe
one more time scan accumulate Dawei
subscribe so on and so forth until that
original source has no more values to
emit so that's kind of what it looks
like in reason land over in typescript
we'll actually see that this looks
almost identical we go and import our
dependencies we have this kind of fancy
pipe that we wrote JavaScript doesn't
yet have a native pipe operator I think
it's coming pretty soon to the language
but we serve a wrapper around that and
then from there on out it's basically
exactly the same as your reason code
call from array with your array you use
the scan operator to accumulate values
delay and then subscribe to it and just
print something out to the console and
keep doing that for every value in the
source until it completes and you can
move on with your debt so I think this
is pretty awesome like the fact that
we're writing a library from the single
source that's working this consistent
way across different code bases and
environments is awesome and I definitely
encourage you all to check out the
Wankel library another really cool
project that contributed to a little bit
is called reprocessing and so this was
written by Avery Morin and Ben Sans
Souci and it's a popular port of the
processing language into reason it
allows you to create these really
complex graphics and visualizations and
people have made some awesome things
with it there's like Perlin noise
visualizations there's small physics
engines for games so I'm going to
actually wrote a cross compiler for this
so you can actually compile it to iOS
and to Android which is pretty darn
awesome
it builds itself as a library inspired
by processing that allows you to create
these cool visualizations that can run
on the web using WebGL and natively
using OpenGL
actually the way that they achieved this
is they have an underlying library
called Reason GL where they wrote the
buckle script bindings to the WebGL API
and then they used oh camel and actually
used oak camels Interop with C to write
bindings to the OpenGL API and then
basically all you have to do as a user
of the library is just tell reprocessing
I want to use the JavaScript back-end or
I want to use the native back-end it's
kind of a one switch flip to get the
exact same visualization running on web
and on native and I think that's that's
super clever here's just like a quick
little demo of what this looks like so I
made kind of a classic bouncing ball
sketch in reprocessing this is kind of
maybe the first thing you do if you're
working on a processing sketch and Kevin
that left terminal I ran this yarn start
command and that basically is just
telling you processing hey go and use
the native Ocampo compiler to compile it
to OpenGL and then on the right-hand
terminal I'm literally just serving that
code over localhost and that's just the
compiled JavaScript that buccal script
output so it's the exact same source
code and you basically just switch out
the back end that you used to compile it
and you have it running exactly the same
and predictably on both web and native
that's I think just absolutely
incredible that we can achieve that
awesome so at this point in the talk
you're probably wondering like why
aren't we rewriting the web or at
minimum our native apps in reason or
maybe you're like I'm not at all
interested in this language but humor me
for a second and go along with me on
this question and and I think there are
kind of a couple ways to approach this I
think we're still really in the early
adopter stage of reason I think we're
kind of viewing this a little bit with
other languages too right now we know
that there are served with JavaScript
that we'd like to fix and we're kind of
figuring out like what is the solution
to that and I think there have been a
ton of good DeBell
in that space and we're all kind of
trying them out right now I think a lot
of us here are probably early adopters
type folks we like to try new things but
you know I I honestly don't think reason
is right for every single team
especially if your core set of
developers our JavaScript devs and who
can work with typescript pretty well
like that might get you pretty far
another thing is that a language is
really I think only as good as the
community around it and secondarily only
as good as its documentation part of
what makes JavaScript so successful is
the community is really big and the
documentation is really good you can
find a lot of resources on getting
started with JavaScript and there are a
lot of ways to just sort of get up and
running with it
I think reason is really lacking in this
fear there is a broader effort underway
to get the documentation to a better
place for newcomers but I have found
myself digging through some pretty
esoteric okay ml documentation and
that's that's a pretty difficult thing
to heap on to new developers and finally
I think reason is really trying to
bridge this divide and and I don't think
this is a really a strong divide but
it's trying to bring together these two
communities that have basically never
talked to one another JavaScript you
know Kamel have been around for roughly
the same amount of time and they haven't
really crossed paths until now so you
know I think it's pretty difficult to
figure out how to reconcile the values
of those two communities and try to come
up with something that's going to work
really well for both of them and I think
it's really natural for that process to
take some time so if really if there's
one thing I want you to take away from
this talk today it's really not that I
think reason is you know the be-all
end-all of how the web is gonna change
rather I think the experiment of reason
kind of shed some light on what we
should be thinking about and what we
should value when considering this
question of what direction is the web
going and I think that can involve kind
of taking technical inspiration from
other languages you know reason has all
the good things immutability by default
typing and type inference these heavy
compiler optimizations it's really
really similar to rust and kind of has
all that good stuff but I think what
feels even more important is really
pushing ourselves to think about how can
we start seeing our programming
communities as these living breathing
organisms that are subject to social and
political difference and how can we
start kind of bridging those divides and
coming together to create something in
the open together that is really
inclusive and really powerful for
everyone yeah that's all I have if you
want to chat with me or have questions
and definitely have to answer those and
you can also hit me up on Twitter or on
the conference Lac and again thank you
so much for your time - anyone have any
questions I know that was a lot of
information yeah so the question is can
you generate webassembly as well and
this is I think maybe the most asked
question in the reason community right
now
and the answer is we're very very close
a few people are working on kind of the
Oh camel - webassembly story and
basically the last thing that they need
to implement is garbage collection and I
think there's a lot of kind of sticking
points with that that are a bit over my
head but we're basically at the point
where once we get the garbage collector
in place the OK mode the webassembly
story will be totally done and again
because reason is basically just a
dialect of oh camel it will totally work
with webassembly at that point as well
so I think in the next year the reason -
webassembly story is going to be ready
for production yeah
yeah so it is something that I
accomplished personally on just side
projects we're sort of considering
investing in it more heavily yet
formidable there is a new UI framework
that came out for reason called reverie
and it kind of provides a react like API
for UI development but it compiles all
down to native code even it has sort of
a very similar Huck's API that react has
so it feels a lot like rewriting react
code but it compiles to super fast
native executables with basically
instant startup and I've actually like
performance tested it against electron
apps with super high intensity data
visualization and it performs
significantly better than an electron
and it really is just not having of
chromium running in your application
yeah
yeah there is there's actually been a
lot of work done in that sphere so
buckle script provides some kind of high
level
api's for serializing and deserializing
your JSON and then recently Jared
Forsyth who's kind of one of the the
biggest most active members of the
reason community created this project
called milk that will actually do
automatic serialization and
deserialization under json for you and
you basically just give it access to you
basically just hit like a back-end
endpoint and then it will actually store
kind of like a local configuration file
for you that will do all the type
inference and serialization in DC or
serialization for you that's also the
case with graph QL where there's kind of
this process set up right now in awhile
the graph QL client libraries one of
which I maintains I'd be happy to chat
about but a them you basically just
point it at your schema it will run an
introspection query on your schema and
then it will actually type check all of
your queries on the client side so you
can basically never form never send
malformed queries to your graph QL API
and you get full type checking at
compile time so it's it's pretty cool
stuff and yeah I think definitely that
story is much more fleshed out and
reason than than in the Ted script world
yeah I have not tried pure script yeah
it's something I've sort of thought
about I think for me the the attraction
to reason kind of happened because the
community was just so welcoming
immediately I'm sure that's probably
saying for the P R script community but
I just haven't really had time to
investigate it but I'm certainly
interested in anything with really
strong static typing and type inference
awesome well I would love to talk to
anyone more about reason after this and
and again thank you so much for coming
it really means a lot
you